[Music]
you
know that the people who want to make
hay
in washington are going to try to use
your adult
son as a cudgel against you
how do you feel about that and what do
you have to say to those people
i have we have great confidence in our
son
i am not concerned about any accusations
but made against him
it's used to get to me i think it's kind
of
foul play but uh look it is what it is
and uh
he's a grown man he is the smartest man
i know
i mean in front of pure intellectual
capacity
well besides peter ducey yelling
questions and getting short answers from
the president-elect
stephen colbert the late show you saw
the question he asked and how it was
answered
by the president-elect about hunter
biden in the federal investigation he's
facing
let's bring our panel start there
charles lane opinion writer for the
washington
post molly hemingway senior editor at
the federalist and tom bevin real clear
politics co-founder
and president molly what about that this
is really the longest answer we've
received
but only to one question yeah it is
embarrassing that biden has not
sat down for an interview with a real
news organization
only being willing to talk to a late
night comedian who offers a very
friendly
question we have uh here though him
saying that he thinks that the
investigation
is a little bit of foul play and this is
inadvertently walking himself toward a
special counsel
when he attempts to meddle in this
investigation
we do have some you know we there the
special counsels are set up when there's
an alleged conflict of interest
obviously the president-elect has great
regard for his son
loves him thinks he's done nothing wrong
we also have
some contemporaneous evidence document
showing that joe biden was somewhat
involved in this biden family business
of selling access to joe biden
to to foreign entities and businesses
you have an eyewitness who says he
discussed this family business
with joe biden and so it might just be
easier for everyone involved to
to just make sure that this
investigation can continue without any
interference
tom last thing on this i mean is it it's
interesting to hear it
used as a cudgel by critics of
of the president-elect in the words of
stephen colbert considering that
media outlets didn't cover the story
before the the election
and social media blacked it out
yeah i mean this was a this was a
massive failing
of of journalism continues to be quite
frankly i mean there are five questions
that biden called on today five news
outlets not a single one of them
brought this subject up and you combine
that with social media the way that they
actively suppress the story
um lock people's accounts and whatnot i
mean it was a real
uh real failure of journalism and and
not that anybody is probably going to be
held to account for it but but it really
did i think
even by the lowest standards of trust in
journalism right now it crossed a line
uh you know further damaging the media's
credibility
well there's a lot of damage that's
being done by this hack
and we don't know the extent of it yet
chuck take a listen to this russia
hacking
this goes back a ways and some analysis
of it today
any specific material if such things
arise we are ready to
analyze together for instance we can
analyze them
through the joint working group on cyber
security
he feels very strongly about it and he
has an interesting idea
make no mistake uh this is a massive
intelligence failure on our part
our goal is always to detect threats way
out left of boom
we failed to do that and now we're
paying the price
intelligence experts believe it was
russia responsible for this hack and
that's going back to july the helsinki
summit your thoughts on this and the
extent of the damage
i think we're only beginning to learn
the extent of the damage
i think what's probably the most
disconcerting aspect of this
very disconcerting story is that it was
essentially
predicted that a couple years ago the
gao had a report on the vulnerabilities
the very vulnerability that the russians
or whoever it was
probably the russians exploited to break
into
so many uh sensitive areas the state
department the commerce department
nih and so it was known that the u.s
cyber security was not capable of
thwarting
just the kind of attack that it was
subject to
now this is going to be i mean obviously
president trump is
more concerned about arguing over the
election than he is about this at this
point so it's going to be front and
center for the new
administration starting in january to
figure out exactly what what went wrong
and how to protect
in the future we tried to get chris
krebs on tonight molly
to talk about this he's been obviously
answering questions from a lot of media
about the election and his statements
about being secure
obviously this happened over several
months and it's a big concern
across the government yeah people were
very
upset with president trump for firing
chris krebs
who was this is in his bailiwick was
handling all of these things and
whether they think he should have been
fired for how he handled election issues
is entirely different from
what was going on here i would love for
people to ask him some questions he just
testified on the hill a few days ago and
it would have been great
for him to answer this but it's not just
this hack which has been attributed to
russia we're not sure
if that is who's responsible but in
recent years china
of course compromised all of those
millions of records of
american citizens through the opm hack
we've had long going
ongoing problems going back quite some
time and we are not taking them as
seriously as we should
we have adversaries all over the world
who would like very much to compromise
all of our systems and have had some
success doing so
and it's incumbent upon us to really
step up here this is the way
that a lot of attacks between countries
are happening now and we have some very
serious adversaries like china
and other countries who have china in
particular which wants to take over
the united states position as the leader
of the of the world and they
have just been given with this election
four more years
of kind of breathing room for them to
advance that so we have to be really on
top of them
and the other countries all right a
quick lightning round a winner and loser
tom you first winner is
pete boudej mayor of midwestern town
fails to run for president
and gets a plum cabinet post despite
having not as
a single uh no experience whatsoever for
the position
if that's not winning i don't know what
it is uh loser mayor lori lightfoot
uh there was a botched chicago uh police
raid in february of 2019.
the video went viral earlier this week
and she said that she
did didn't know anything about it turns
out she did as of last year bad week for
lori lightfoot
all right chuck quick win or loser
the winner's obvious joe biden the
electoral college made him president of
the united states on monday and the
loser
many losers all the people who have been
enabling this absurd
idea by the president's been putting out
that the election was stolen
molly wrap it up winner loser my
winner is governor christie gnome of
south dakota she's faced intense
media bullying to shut down her state
has not done so and has the
excellent budget and low unemployment
rate to to show for it
my loser is adam schiff and everyone in
the media who perpetrated the
conspiracy theory that the 2016 election
was stolen by trump colluding with
russia
and caused so much damage over the last
couple of years new texts showed once
again that this was a ridiculous theory
that never should have been trafficked
in by the media or adam schiff
bill barr saying the department of
justice was being used as a political
weapon
to topple an administration that to the
wall street journal tonight
panel thank you have a great weekend